ladies and gentlemen director david
leitch that was like a you know old
television show or they rehearsed it and
you know something they wouldn't
actually do it I didn't like the movie
we're gonna start with a few fun
questions to get to warm you up
what TV what TV show would you love to
guess direct hmm well this is you know I
think better call Saul is something I'd
really like to if anyone's a fan I love
Bob Odenkirk work I mean I'm a huge
Breaking Bad fan I love that dark world
I love the comedy in it and it'd just be
really fun I think that'd be a great one
huh what movie have you seen the most
wow that's really you know there's a lot
that come to mind I would probably say
The Big Lebowski or it's gonna be really
embarrassing happy gilmore come on it's
great it's great film I love it
no there's all I'd have to think I mean
I mean there are movies that I love to
revisit and that those two obviously
it's funny I'm an action guy but I do
love comedy and those two comedies come
to mind and I'm a huge fan of the Coen
brothers so you know anything that they
do is it's amazing what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once if any what TV show
oh I grew up on mash so I think that you
know watching you know the mash and the
reruns for you know years and years and
years you know that's probably dating me
sorry what you you've obviously worked
in the stunt business for a while so
what stunt or stunts have you seen
recently that have really floored you
and you can't just say John wick
dammit because I was gonna say like I
think that the sort of that opening
first act in John wick has some really
great compelling stuff that you don't
but the first one of the third one no
and the third one but the first one
that's like I thought you were talking
about your movie I'm like wait a minute
but the
the third one I mean that that sort of
gauntlet of gags that you know Chad and
the team came up with was like really
you know friggin impressive and it's um
it's fun to see that stuff go down and
and Keanu was like one of those guys who
get in there and do it and it's it's
really refreshing to see and fun to see
yeah I think John wick theories what
they did there is amazing moving on
what's your favorite ride at Disneyland
I couldn't tell you man I think it's a
small world that's a good ride I got it
that works we don't spend a lot of time
there actually you know something I have
learned that there are some people I
just learned that uh-oh
schewe tell it how do you pronounce it
yeah so he just told me he's never been
to Disneyland and but I've met people
that are saying they've never anyway
we're off on a tangent let's get let's
go further what do you collect what do I
collect Wow I collect shoes tennis shoes
my Kelly McCormack is here it's like
giving the answers producer Kelly
McCormack ladies and gentlemen he's here
Deadpool - atomic blonde - Shaw little
movies that she does also his better
half yes also my wife but a funny story
not funny story real story the reason I
got the atomic blonde job at that time
was called cold the city that was her
movies so nepotism works she really
fought for me to get that gig and thank
God because that was really fun so
tennis shoes tennis shoes yeah so I'm
not wearing any tonight but I do
probably have more than I need sure when
I don't play tennis that much they're
comfortable there I want to jump
backwards in your career real quick a
lot of people in here will know David
from what he's directed recently but you
have a long history in Hollywood doing
stunts one of the things you did was I
think you doubled or did the stunts for
Brad Pitt in Fight Club yes which is yes
exactly a lot it Wow yeah
so talk talk a little bit about because
I love that movie and you got to work
with Fincher and you
with bread yeah it was it was actually
one of the sort of biggest moments in my
stunt career early on it sort of put me
on the map if you know anything about
the the movie business it's all sort of
like once you're in its its connections
and making impressions and like you know
you know making relationships with
people and it was a really big
opportunity
that being said like being on Fight Club
there was very little fighting really
when you look at the movie there's very
little fighting so the the job of the
stunt double in that movie was we were
training the actors we were
choreographing these fights with Jared
Leto at the time and at Norton and we
were working together with the stunt
team you know shooting rehearsals and
then you know I think like the biggest
gag I did on that movie was like climb a
fence to pull out the fat stuff in the
dumpster and maybe take some punches
over the shoulder or something cuz there
wasn't a lot of stunts but there was a
stump presence on that movie and again
like hat being on that film for with
those people like watching Fincher work
watching Jeff Amata the coordinator at
the time who became one of my mentors um
work and getting to you know work with
Brad was really good and I got to work
with him on four or five other movies it
was really great time so you also did
stunts on 300 yes which is did a lot
more stunts than 300 right maybe one or
two yeah what do you because I mean
that's another fantastic film what do
you remember from making that one uh
that was another really sort of special
time in in choreography and at that time
it was um Chad and Damon Caro was and
myself were all sort of part of a group
and we were you know choreographers we
had rented a facility we were
choreographing and shooting stuff you
this thing we call stunts vis now that
seems like everybody does but we would
shoot and edit our fight scenes and Zach
was really into that so Damon had worked
with Zach a lot and we sort of built the
support team around Damon and
we had I think 1520 stunt guys that
played the Spartans around the main cast
and we had a training camp which was
three months in Montreal we we all you
know ate like this crazy diet and we all
trained our asses off and we did
choreography every day with the actors
and then we did weight training and we
sort of it was like again like this
really beautiful time where we all got
paid to you know learn and and grow and
I think some special choreography came
out of that and that's obviously a
testament to Zach and his visual style
but it was also you know people were
ready for something more you know
graphic and fawn and visceral and we got
the actors to do it that's thing like if
you look at the movies that Chad and I
direct we try to get the actors to do it
and be involved and you to do that you
have to train them and that was like one
of our first sort of test cases in
movies where we got to do that and it
paid off you get to Gerard like you know
killing a bunch of guys it was pretty
cool yeah we're almost at Hobbes in Shaw
I swear I definitely want to touch on
you got to work with the Wachowskis a
lot and I love the Wachowski 's and you
worked on the matrix we worked on which
ones the second and third I worked on
the second and third yeah
right so what did you take away from
because they're amazing what did you
take away from working with them that
may be impacted you as a director you
know was that one of those experiences
or making those movies yeah I mean I
could look at I couldn't even begin to
categorize what I took away I mean
because it was such an in sort of a sort
of impression oppression is the time of
my life where I was really wanting to be
a filmmaker and they were allowing us to
hmm direct splinter units and they
really liked our stunts vis that I you
know I talked about earlier and they
were really encouraging us to go out
there and do that stuff and and they
would use it and we'd have conversations
and we really became you know part of
the the creative family on on those
movies and yeah I mean so many things I
I think really their passion for film
their their discipline in storytelling
their composition their their use of
color and I think the biggest thing is
the bold choices you know I think you
you just swing for the fences and you do
something you it's not like you fit into
a box you just break the box open you
know you just you've reinvent the genre
and I think I've always tried to do it
you know Chad and I with John wick it's
like a you know it was really when we
got the script it was kind of like a
programmer like it's a thriller or
action thing and we're like how do we
make this how do we flip this thing on
its head and atomic blonde when we were
you know Kelly and I were starting with
it it was really a Cold War thriller if
you look at the original you know
coldest city it's just a noir not just
in a war like how do we flip it on its
head and I think with Hobbes and Shaw
not to segue but you know it's an 80s
buddy action movie but how do i
contemporize it and how do I make it fun
and how do I make it flip it on its head
and like make it something else and they
taught me that because they make bold
choices and they're not afraid and I
think as filmmakers you have to be brave
or you'll never get noticed you know
what was cooler directing all the things
you've directed in the features or
directing Celine Dion's music video
Wow now I will say like that's a hard
question because I think you know the
fur I've always wanted we should let
people know it's for the song ashes from
dead yes yes so we there's a lot of
great stories but you know the sort of
like really beautiful moment was the
first time we were there with all the
cameras are set we got like 5 cameras
classic music video style the techno
crane scooping around and like she's
gonna sing the first time normally
they're just kind of lip-synching to the
playback but she wants to sing it the
first time and I remember like she sings
the whole song through and I couldn't
yell cut like cuz I'm like I'm like a
little verklempt and like everyone's got
goose bumps and I just see like the
dolly grip like keep swinging the crane
and there's a tear in his eye and
everyone's like what the hell is going
on and they're like you're gonna call
cut now you gotta call cut oh my god a
call cut she's amazing and it you know
there's a reason why she she does what
she does and she has you know they built
a you know they built a stage for her to
do it in four years and it was amazing
experience you're thanked in the credits
of baby driver yes why you know yeah
totally I do I do
I am holy [ __ ] no so early on Edgar
Wright was a you know had reached out to
Chad and myself because he was really
planning something special with that
movie and he had a very specific plan of
like what he wanted to do editorially
and action wise and music wise so we had
both gone to him and like we went in and
had meetings with him and talked about
him talked about the theory of action
and like things that maybe we would do
and actually made the connection for
darren prescott eventually to direct
second unit with him so it was just more
yeah having conversations with him about
the action and as Laura filmmaker to
filmmaker and I look we're huge fans of
his I I am particularly Hot Fuzz
probably one of those movies I've seen
as much as happy gilmore so I do love
his stuff yeah he's uh he hasn't missed
as a girl maker he's a true or not true
we're getting into Hobbes and Shaw now
is it true or not true that each Rosella
would only do the movie by how if he had
a song in the soundtrack no that's not
true she was excited about it no he was
really excited I'm totally teasing I
obviously that wasn't the reason
absolutely not I'm not doing well how
did we get in the soundtrack um so we
were on set one day and it was actually
early on in the the shooting in London
you know in between takes he's working
on his iPad or some electronic device
and he's like you know putting some
beats down he's got his headphones on
and then he like pulls his headphones
off as like hey I'm writing a song for
the you know the movie I got inspired
I've been working on my character I got
some ideas and I'm like great and then a
couple days later he kind of does a
little bit more of it I mean it's like
I'm gonna play for you when it's ready
but it's not ready and then I'd see him
over the next weeks he would work on it
and and then he tell me he told me he's
like I'm gonna go to the studio it's
gonna take me a week and I'm gonna lay
it down properly and then I'm gonna send
you the demo and no [ __ ] he does it he
lays it down sends me the demo and it's
just him on it
Cypress Hill was not on it yet and I'm
like this is good man like this could
really work like I you know I love it I
it's hard for me to know yet cuz we
gotta wait till the movies put together
in it I have a lot of music in my movies
and I and there's sort of it's I'm very
particular and I have a vision for them
so when a new song comes in it's a
little bit of like let me rest on it but
then he went and got Cypress Hill on it
and he's like I'm gonna continue to
polish it I'm gonna thicken to need to
polish it so we got in a post he sent me
the final version and it was pretty
quick where everyone was like holy crap
this is a really great track you hear it
in the credits but you also hear it in
the car chase at the end of the CIA sort
of the descender sequence the McLaren
chase that's the the song that we
dropped there and it was easy it was
undeniable but he was patient he you
know kept working on it and that's how
we got it in
and they don't have a they really don't
have that many songs from the artists
and the fast franchise end up in the
movies it's it's kind of rare you know
you think you have the tie
ludicrous and they haven't they've had
some but it's not like it happens every
time so it's kind of cool when it all
works out I'm most movies take like two
years to make beginning to end sometimes
longer you made this I believe you said
in 13 months yeah it was 13 months from
beginning to end we took the gig at we
were finishing post on Deadpool 2 when
the opportunity sort of fruit was
presented and then there was a release
date already and kind of look at that
calendar and you go wow that is
aggressive and that's going to be hard
and that's gonna be challenging but
there's also like a real opportunity
here to do something special and it's
like we had to look each other and gar
you in are you in and like we're in and
so we said yes and dug in but it was um
it was aggressive and I think harder
than physical production was post the
the 22 weeks of post is uh I don't wish
that on anyone of a film this size but
again it's just about the people you
surround yourself with and like you know
can you you have the right people they
step up and they stay awake all night
and they deliver what is it like how did
you get the project did someone at
Universal call you like how what was
that initial meeting like and what is it
like knowing that if I say yes to this
this is the next year or two of my life
you know and I'm sure you had other
things that you were thinking about
doing at the same time yeah I think this
project was kind of interesting how it
came to us because I think we were I was
really interested in like working again
on the heels of Deadpool and you know
this script had been around and they'd
been looking for directors and we were
looking at the landscape of stuff that
was going to go right away there wasn't
a bunch of things that we're gonna go
right away
and I think it was a it was Kelly who
sort of saw it out there made connected
the dots and got us the draft and we
read it and then it was that sort of
moment of like it's Hobson shot like
their dynamic is really incredible and
the comedy that they generate and their
sort of chemistry together is so
fun we could do something special like
throwback eighties buddy action movie
and turn it on its head and so when that
opportunity sort of crystallized it was
pretty easy for us to say we want to do
this and the talk with the studio was
really easy at that point I mean we had
other things even at the studio that
were circling but they wanted this they
were really supportive of me as a
filmmaker to do something special with
it and not have to be beholden to
everything in the fast world and that it
had its own tone and it had its own sort
of you know vision and they were really
like we want you to do something
different but you know make sure it
appeals to fast fans that kind of thing
so you get the script you're looking at
it and you're like okay we're gonna make
the project how much is what's on screen
similar to what you were sort of given
on that day and how much is it sort of
you know you working with Chris and then
Drew and you know putting this thing
together
oh it's wildly different than that first
draft and that wasn't just me like I
mean we you know we had the script and
like Hobbs and char in it a couple of
the set pieces are there and the big
ideas but there was a lot of things that
I wanted to do in terms of how these
guys how their world worked compared to
the fast world and we needed to like
crack that stuff you know like again
like how they travel around like for
example the airport sequence you know
the TSA scene like putting them in these
situations where they could be at odds
with each other was really important to
me and so we had to figure out that
structure changing some of the set
pieces was important to me just from an
action standpoint and then there's a lot
on a movie like this there's a lot of
people that need to put their stamp on
it as well
you know Jason was you know we're
reinventing him and this in this new
incarnation as a hero so we had to build
him out
in a different way there's a lot of
things that had to be addressed that
weren't on the page we sort of just
jumped right in he's a hero
you know Hobbs was gonna take on an
evolution from who he was in the fast
world and we're sort of like gearing him
into we're gonna drop him into the spy
world so there was a lot of work to be
done and
but luckily everybody sort of got on
board and knew that it these bones are
great and the premise is great and
there's some great set piece ideas but
how do we make this even better and how
do we make it work for all these people
that are on board and signing away their
life for a year so yeah making every
actress say yes yes yeah yeah in a
plight way yeah so I listen the action
is great but my favorite bits are in
this movie are all the scenes of Dewayne
and Jason insulting each other like that
stuff is fantastic and it's really funny
so what is it like writing those scenes
and how much is being figured out like
just talk about crafting those scenes
it's funny I mean again like that is
honestly what drew me and and and us to
the material there was a great scene in
the original script which was like the
opening pages of them they were
bickering and fighting in a garage or
whatever and that dialogue that that
Chris Morgan had written was priceless
and we still repurposed a lot of those
insults back into the new CIA office
where we first meet them so that's again
like that was the DNA of the script that
that lived working with those guys
moving forward like building out that
comedy was um was kind of simple in a
way I mean they they both would come to
set with really particular ideas of like
a list of insults it wasn't like a lot
of improv on set it was more like they
had been sitting at home fuming thinking
like how am I gonna insult this guy in
front of me in a good way you know kind
of like how you're gonna you know get
one over on your best friend and so it
was really fun like getting him that
first day in the CIA office that was the
first time that we had Duane on set
actually we'd shot with Jason for a week
before that and it was a little
stressful we had the script pages out
you know cameras are ready to go but
everyone took a break have the crew
leave let's run the pages to see how the
dynamic works and the first insult
insult out of the mouth is you know like
you know Harry Potter voice and those
two lines and you're like people are
already like laughing behind the monitor
and you're like this is gonna be great
it's gonna be great
and so leaning into that dynamic was
really important and finding
opportunities to you know to do more of
it was the goal you were allowed in a
pg-13 movie one f-bomb and you get both
of them to say it so what was that
always the plan to use that f-bomb and
that sequence was there ever a thought
of putting it somewhere else yeah I mean
that was the only way I could have
walked out of that movie alive I think
that you know we wanted to make sure
that everybody got sort of Hobbs and
Chaka had a fair play and everything
that we did you know it was really
important to me that the characters were
balanced and that you know this movie
was both of theirs and that was sort of
like the pinnacle moment like who gets
to say you know [ __ ] in the movie well
they both have to say it because really
how else are we gonna do it and it kind
of led us to a really special moment you
know where you're we we don't we come up
with the split-screen idea of
introducing these characters in sort of
that fun visual way and then that to
repay that off with the split screen
where they both say you know [ __ ] way
it was um it was really landed well and
the MPAA said yes so that was good
because we weren't sure they were gonna
so we rolled the dice on that one
because we didn't really have an out
like [ __ ] if they don't say yes then I
guess we cut that out well technically
it's all it's just one word yeah so said
bye to people exactly where did the line
black Superman come from and how and
talk about casting he dress because he's
you know it's cedrus well I'll put I
want to just I'll throw my drama into
the ring on that whole black Superman
thing because I know there's two posing
stories out there Dwayne says he he came
up with it Idris feels it was improv
this is we were moving so fast on this
movie and like those it's hard to know
like who came up with that idea
I honestly it could have been interest
improv it could have been Dwayne we were
trying to figure out a solution for this
joke that we were pitching which was the
black James Bond that was going to be
the line looking
like I'm like the black James Bond that
was the line and we were kind of looking
for alts and and it was either Idris
rifted or Dwyane rifted and came up with
it so there's opposing stories I don't
know all I know is when he set it on
camera
everyone got fired up and we're like
that's in the movie but you wanted me to
talk about interest casting like yeah
that could be possibly one of the
coolest moments in my life like you know
walking into the Soho House and where I
was meeting him in London and like
seeing him sitting in a corner and he's
like hey man you know like just Alba
like I'm gonna go say hi to this guy
like we're buds right this is so cool
he's so cool right and you go up and
he's like oh man you know I really love
your work like I'm really excited let's
talk about this character and from the
beginning we had a real easy
relationship and it was a really great
conversation about what he wanted to do
in this movie with what he had in front
of him in terms of what the character
was and at that time it wasn't as
layered as we ended up making it you
know we knew we wanted to make someone
who had some heightened powers that
could take on these two sort of
larger-than-life you know he rose and he
was down with that but he wanted to make
sure that we added an element of
humanity and so we were we went back and
forth of like how do you make Brixton
diabolical but also empathetic and and
that led us to some really cool
discoveries about how the director works
in the world and like where interest
where addresses characters at the end of
the movie it was really great working
with him I mean he had just getting you
know done directing his own film so I
think he was in a really fun a really
good place to you know collaborate
closely with the director and also
empathize with me like there was a lot
of moving parts on this movie and it was
good to have someone in the back just
like calm and like I've been there you
know on a smaller scale but you know and
never you know getting upset about
anything just like in it how do we make
it better so yeah he's he's so cool I
have to say he is the coolest guy what
planet not only the sexiest but probably
the coolest guy
obviously you have a history with stunts
and stunts or an in a huge part of your
life what will it take to get stunts the
respect / award stuff that they deserve
I honestly don't know and I think that
it has been really it's been really odd
like especially the last sort of like
five or six years that you see the push
for you know you know the Academy to
recognize stunts and they just keep
turning it down and turning it down and
you don't feel like the voices are heard
and they're the you know forces are
mobilizing and like trying to you know
get the awareness out there but it's
really kind of like sad you know every
department that works on a movie in in
physical production is recognized you
know and so there's one time every year
that every single department head gets
to celebrate and all your friends on set
are celebrating except the stunt
department you know movies like Mad Max
or you know fast and furious so you saw
the credits you guys sat through them
thank you that's a lot of stunt people
that give a lot of their you know blood
sweat and tears to making this movie
great and it's really odd that they
can't find a way to recognize them and I
don't know when it's going to happen and
it's you know I'm gonna do everything I
can know to at least get it out there
and like maybe mobilize you know
directors you know and I know that
Quentin is doing something in front of
the the movie I heard that there's a
there's a promotion for you know to
recognize stunts in front of the Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood so I actually
don't know that yet I think one of the
things though is maybe people are not
sure what to nominate whether it be like
the person who designs the stunt the
actual performer maybe it needs to be
two different things I mean I'm just
throwing out you know just being like
wow I think that and right you know
there's no there is no
but that can be figured out with a
conversation I mean sag yo I mean sag
does it we have best ensemble award the
stunt ensembles so you're not
recognizing just the coordinator you're
recognizing everyone who was involved in
stunts the coordinator takes the award
but it doesn't like you know you know
whatever put the coordinator on a
pedestal because it honestly stunts like
most departments it's like very very
collaborative and you need like the
performers to actually do the stuff that
you design so yeah I think giving it to
a coordinator is open for discussion but
giving it to the ensemble makes sense to
me but again like we should be at least
having those conversations with the
Academy and like you know maybe there's
multiple categories and not a lot but
like no and though I don't think it's
part of the confusion I think there's
some other stumbling block with the
Academy that I'm not quite clear on I
don't want to reveal specifics because
of spoilers but I do want to talk about
there are some interesting cameos in
this movie without getting into
specifics I'm curious how they were they
easy to pull off was it hard was it
because it's been under wraps movies you
know coming out tomorrow and people
don't know holy [ __ ] yeah I gotta get
home no I'm just kidding that's great
that's so cool um look whit in terms of
like they were honestly relatively easy
and I think that that's a testament to
Dwayne and hopefully myself that people
would want to come out and and have fun
in this world but the goal of it was to
push the tone in the direction that I I
was hoping for for this universe going
forward we had such a great dynamic
between Hobbs and Shaw and there was
such fun in chemistry and comedy that I
wanted to make sure that we had other
components of that within the movie so
it didn't feel atonal and who better to
bring on than the people who we were to
get and Wow like so fortunate but again
like it was where I really had a vision
to take the this franchise and hopefully
it works for the audience and
we will you know hopefully there's a
promise of it moving forward in that
construct would be great when I saw the
film for the first time the audience
like went crazy I was not in here when
the first cameo happened I'm assuming
you guys like all laughter ass off you
know because it's it's really um it's
already funny yes it's it's really funny
guy yeah he's an a-hole for being
talented so before I open it up to the
audience how much are you pre how much
are you figuring out the way you're
gonna shoot things before you get to set
and how much is it in the moment you're
looking at what you have and you're
pulling out and you're working you the
DP to figure out you know how you're
gonna shoot a sequence and I'm gonna
talk about the action I mean like say
like the fist if between Jason and
Dwayne on the plane when they're
insulting each other how much is that
figuring it out in the moment we had
talked about having Jonathan Sela here
unfortunately he was out of town because
I thought it would have been really fun
his BP yeah DP that I worked with since
John wick but we are really particular
and I I think you can probably tell
sometimes by our composition like it's
pretty planned I mean we were a little
bit more fluid on this because of just
the nature of the the the movie and the
voices and the changes with all the
dynamics that go on in a big studio
movie with a lot of personalities we had
to react but like example of that scene
on the plane like we'd shot listed it
you know three weeks before and we knew
all our angles and we now have a
separate we have a very close
relationship we have a second language
really how we talk but you know we knew
it was a matter of like six setups and
where the cameras are going to be in
what lenses we were gonna use we're
really particular that way but again
like we're also good with having to be
spontaneous but I like having a plan I
say the best plan we had Kelly can
attest to this on atomic blonde we had
the entire movie shot listed and color
coded and she was always so proud of
that because she's like on this one it
was like a little bit more of a chaotic
thing for a producer like are you gonna
make your day how's it going to work
happen we're on atomic maan we knew like
every everything was like color-coded
for visual effects or crane or Steadicam
because on a movie like that with less
resources like you if you only needed to
Crane one day you only brought it one
day here you have the crane every day
because it's that type of movie and you
don't know what's gonna happen and you
need it and it's big and scope Ian so
we're planned I was gonna say I think
Fincher said that one of the reasons he
doesn't do a lot of crane shots or I
forget exactly what he said but it's
basically I would rather have all that
money for an overtime you know thing
it's true I mean they get you know that
stuff adds up like all that equipment
hmm you know if you look at just a crane
bringing an extra operator bringing
someone to operate the remote head it's
like all of a sudden three people and
the rental on the thing and then the
delivery it's like a three day rental
and you guys know who are filmmakers you
know that all that money counts and so
on a big movie like this that money
doesn't have as much impact in the
bigger scope of the budget but on a
small movie it means everything and you
really have to be planned so it's kind
of great that I got to do some smaller
movies not only as a director but even
in the second unit space coming up like
you just you know how do I shoot this
with one camera and you know we haven't
even open we haven't even opened the
door on all of the second unit stuff
which is a whole nother thing but where
is the catch box wait who has it so that
is the magical thing for asking quick
you want to throw it at people instead
of us or do you want do you want to
throw it at people you guys can I don't
want to let's start right there top the
top is speaking to the top I'm sorry
what's your name oh I'm Kim hey Kim you
mentioned to be brave I just wanted to
see from you like what are some of the
bravest moments you've had to take in
your career in terms of being a director
yeah yeah I think there's a couple I
mean look that's sort of then you're
kind of like patting yourself on the
back like hey
so brave look at what I did but I think
that the the idea with Lorraine
Broughton in atomic blonde where we did
the single camera you know one shot for
seven eight minutes was um kind of brave
for that time you know I think people
had done it and it wasn't like we were
reinventing the wheel but for me first
time out I wasn't co-directing we needed
to make a bold choice I wanted to put I
wanted to hang that moment on a great
actor and stay with them and I knew that
that's what would get me through this
scene so if you could just like stay
with Charlize rip out all the score just
be in the sound design and like be you
know make this provocative bold choice
there were no editorial outs by the way
and um Kelly can attest to this like the
focus was always sort of prodding us
they were super supportive but their
prodding like maybe just one out like
maybe you could cut it at the stairwell
if we wanted to like you know what if we
tested it it was too violent and and we
were just like no no and so that was a
bold choice and I have to say that that
was again like having a producer that
inspires you to do those things and take
those risks is really important because
that was Kelly's idea like she's like
you've been trying to do this one shot
for years here's the time did the
budgets small you're gonna have the
control figure it out and man a lot of
logistics went into that but it paid off
it paid off like I can't it's the most
memorable scene in that movie and
without that moment I don't think that
the film would have got as recognized
that you know sort of in the action
space that that shot is I'm gonna it's
[ __ ] awesome thank you it's sad I love
it it's great and so it really is where
we is it let's see let's just did you
have a question then let's go right
there my name is Cameron in the
mid-nineties
I do man I joined this place called
Minnesota martial arts academy shut the
hell up yeah
really this little in the mid-90s yep
Brooklyn Center yes and you were sitting
on a couch
really that's what anything out
yeah and just and you you were an
instructor at the time okay
I think you I think you cornered my
friend Akbar Mohammed really okay couple
months ago okay so just see where your
career started from there to where you
are today man it's it's awesome
congratulations ah thank you that's
pretty cool that's really cool yeah um
Greg Nelson who obviously is a huge
friend of mine he still has his martial
arts school now in a better massive
facility and training great fighters and
that was a really formidable you know
time in my life and that's cool man
thanks for sharing that that's tripping
me out right now that's freaking out
right now
absolutely I just had a quick two-part
question what was the best takeaway from
second unit when you got into directing
and the second part of that is what was
wisdom gained when you got in the
director's chair well I think it's good
it's I can answer probably with the one
answer and it is you know directing
second unit you're presented with all
these these these challenges
logistically like we were just talking
about budget you're dealing with
different sized movies you're dealing
with different directors and you're
getting to watch everybody style and
you're getting to see a lot of times
their problems and the mistakes they
made because second units often called
to fix them you know you're like oh [ __ ]
you know well second unit we'll clean it
up and you're like how do we get here
you know you're like oh that's why and
so you've really presented with like
oftentimes the mistakes that were made
and you're you're finding solutions so
going into directing first unit in terms
of like the logistics of making a movie
you've seen a lot of pitfalls and you
can anticipate those and you can you
know not make them so and you can
deliver action on different size budgets
because you've had that experience
that's what I want to throw that thing
we should do unless you have a let's
what we should throw it somewhere is
anyone well throw it hold on I want to
go far is anyone
over there I then let's just go right
there I'll be I'll be good let's throw
it that did not throw so people who are
watching this there's a bow what is that
like a puffy ball yeah with a microphone
with a microphone my name is Ryan just
want to know who was a bigger diva the
rocker wow that is a great provocative
question that I could get in a lot of
trouble for answering honestly they're
not on set these guys come in and they
want to work I'd worked with Jason for a
long time on movies as a second unit
director as a choreographer even as a
stunt man he threw me out of a bus
window in the mechanic so we go way back
way back but the the you know they're
not they're not they don't have that
diva presence on set they're there
they're sort of journeyman action guys
and great professionals and they show up
to work and they treat the crew of the
respect and Dwayne Dwayne is just this
sort of font of positivity when he shows
up and like wants to make sure that
everyone's sort of taken care of and the
actors are you know being supported and
how are we building up the other cast
and he's great so never follow up
question again I wouldn't wanna I
wouldn't want to put my money on either
one of them right because I think
they're gonna fight to the death and you
might just have to call the morgue
so no they're they're both I've seen
incredible athletes and super tough in
their own right so I don't know who do
you think I think I think that in a day
or two you should go to Collider and
watch a supercut that this guy is
currently cutting which includes things
that you might enjoy I promise you I did
the junket and you know I promise you
something fun is coming that involves
exactly what you want to know yes
let's let's throw right down here well
actually no we're not throwing there
because it's near the camera let's go
you guys you got thrown it to you guy
yeah turn around
okay all right good teamwork that's it
just like Hobbs in shop teamwork guys I
didn't drop I can save the world we come
together I like the way they continued
on the theme of family which is
obviously prevalent throughout the whole
Fast & Furious franchise was there ever
a discussion about including Owen Shaw
or was that just too logistically
difficult obviously there's a lot going
on in the script already and bringing
the actors together yeah again a lot you
guys are so good because you kind of
answer your own questions which is great
but I think that we were I'm not trying
to be a dick just being honest because
that was really what happened like we
had so much story to carry and like it
was really and we wanted to give space
for Vanessa's character Hattie to really
have you know life and so I think it was
really just a conscious decision at some
point like we'll focus on one sibling
for this one timeout we still at the
back story with brixton and Idris on the
Shaw side so there's a lot of narrative
going on and thinking of adding you know
the sort of Luke's character would have
you know maybe been a bridge too far but
we make reference to him in the in the
thing and the promise that he'll be
obviously in the Shaw world and you know
we'd love to have him at least I would
and there's this little there's a
flashback scene where we have young Owen
but people kind of miss him because the
explosions going off and the money's in
the air and you see a kid in the back
and he's like doing this but he's there
and Helens character obviously mentions
him but it was really just too much
story for us to say like you know let's
let's giving us a moment
didn't I actually missed that so that's
an easter egg yeah I wasn't it meant to
be it's just a lot of smoke I think but
yes there's an easter egg yeah yes let's
go right there hi Tori
we're gonna try and say this in a
non-spoiler way I like that but I
noticed in this movie there's a lot of
moments when you see Hobson shocked kind
of confronting the mistakes they've made
in their past and obviously this one
focuses a lot on family I was wondering
if you were going to continue with that
trend in the future of them seeing their
mistakes and trying to fix them because
it seems like something big might be
coming up for one of them yeah I know
what you're leaning into and I think
that it's um it's that is part of our
journey with Shaw in a sense like we you
know he started in the franchise as a
villain it was easier for Hobbs he
started in the franchise as a hero so we
needed to make sure that we spent time
in the narrative to understand his
backstory see him connect with his
family gain empathy with these you know
the audience see his humanity and I
think you know Jason stepped up and took
risks as a as an actor and played
vulnerable moments with with Vanessa and
played vulnerable moments with Helen and
like that I had never seen him do in a
long long time so we could start to take
that road back and there's a line in the
movie where he says I have to make
amends for things that I've done and and
we plan on doing that and it was just
again like so much story to tell
buffing out Hobbes's world buffing out
Shaw's world you know striking a pose
tonally for what we wanted to do there
was you know only so many places we
could go so I think that's what you're
talking about okay I know yeah yeah I
want to jump into it but let's go right
there hey Devin yeah my name is Vaughn
we're going up becoming film editor and
every time I watch a new movie I try to
look for filmmakers that inspire me
editorially your movies are like the
coolest crap man like so good like
you're like the coolest filmmaker one of
the coolest working thank you and you
talk about like being brave as a
filmmaker you also direct a Deadpool -
and I've always wanted to know this
Logan had just come out and then the
opening of that Deadpool - movie
you have a music box that is recreating
the scene of that iconic ending so whose
idea was that and please tell me
somebody has that music box at their
house because I wanted I I don't know
but if I had to guess who had it it's
probably Ryan Reynolds or the Fox prop
Department I don't know that's from the
twisted mind of Ryan I mean that was
definitely a yeah that's a you know I
even was sort of I had what's funny is I
had just done additional photography
with with James Mangold on the death
scene of Logan and so we had we done and
he brought me out we did some
choreography I just there as a friend
and 8711 guys were there and we did some
choreography for that last little fight
around the truck and the death again and
so it was funny like whatever four
months later I'm sitting on set and we
had this little clay model of Logan
impaled on a tree and and it's just like
I can't I mean I was there working on it
spins with James and we're friends and
yet it's spinning and that's Ryan has a
such a great sensibility about like
these odd things that you know you're
gonna find I mean at my first impression
was I don't know if this is gonna work
and then you know you're sitting on set
watching it happen and you're like [ __ ]
this is gold but it's cool so yeah I
give that all to mr. Reynolds yep let us
bring it behind right up there great
movie thanks man
have you ever like has an idea of or
anything in a script ever come to you
that you thought was like you looked at
someone else and said that's absolutely
impossible we can't do that and then
ended up doing like what's one of the
most difficult challenges you've ever
had first stunt so it's a hard question
because I mean I think that you know you
they all look pretty hard know they're
all like mind-numbingly looked hard like
I can't you know I think the idea I'll
give you this anecdote about the cars
suspended from the helicopter so that
was an idea that came in late at the
game we had already landed in Hawaii we
had
still we had like six seven weeks of
shooting left and we had some resources
where I had such the stunt team we're
all on the island we could splinter off
like I could get all the lead ups for
this great action you know we can expand
the sequence and the studio was
interested in it I was interested in it
but it's like you know and they're like
well if you do it can you do some big
iconic idea that's sort of like fast
fast Ian's right and we're like okay and
so putting together the chains of cars
with honestly two weeks of prep with
special effects visual effects cranking
out a previz storyboard artists you know
drawing crazily you know after after
shoot meetings with stunts practical
effects the producers the studio
budgeting that little bit getting the
extra money to do it was crazy and then
effects building rigs to you know drive
the cars on two wheels like so we're so
it feels like they're suspended so
you're driving a truck and then you have
a stunt driver driving another truck on
two wheels with a little sort of proxy
wheel behind him to make it look like
it's being suspended from the Black Hawk
then working with the Black Hawk pilot
to choreograph you know the exact
distance of what the chain would be from
that truck to here with a helicopter
pilot filming the whole thing yeah in
like three weeks of prep for that moment
while we're shooting so there's a whole
unit like prepping that sequence because
we came up with the idea and I don't
know that's probably the craziest thing
we ever decided I wonder what that first
conversation you have where you pitch it
to that person would be at a producer
eyes are some curious with that
relationships like where you come up
with this crazy idea and say oh whoa we
want to suspend all these cars off a
cliff
I guess in the fast world they're kind
of used to it because they're like he's
chasing a submarine in the last one
right but so they were kind of like yeah
okay
and so we do in the fast world but there
was also they also knew it was me and
they were like oh [ __ ] he's going to try
and do some of this stuff whereas like
in the fast world they do some epic
practical stuff and Spiro who shoots
their second unit does some incredible
stuff but there was a lot in times that
the the CG and the stunts aren't
integrated in the way that I was hoping
they could be and so we really tried to
do a lot of that in that sequence for
the time and the resources that we had
and so challenging effects to build cars
that drive on two wheels is pretty crazy
in three weeks so yeah and a bold move
thank you very
it's how you make it move right all
interconnected but listen I'm sure Duane
was like oh wait I'm gonna be able to
pull a helicopter with a chain yeah
we're filming this he was in he was in
and he did like the idea of you hanging
out over the cliff and there was a lot
of things like in some of the keyframes
and you send him to marketing a movie
like this there's a lot of um you know
marketing that they support it and they
go we love that idea let's um you know
let's do it
and they're like we support it and so a
machine like this that means a lot where
is that gonna let's throw it right over
there hello hey hey my name is laQuan in
the pond are you doing good man hurry
I'm good I'm good I was wondering a
Vanessa Kirby what kind of could you
talk about her prep for all the action
yeah
first first and foremost about Vanessa
she's a wonderful person but she's also
an incredible actress and I've said this
before a lot of times in interviews I
never go wrong when you bet on a great
actor and she came in and like all good
actors wants to deliver a real physical
performance to bring her character to
life not only the dramatic stuff that
she obviously can do you know with her
eyes closed and so she was really
excited to get to do action and I
pitched her like hey she was concerned
you know mission she got the train but
she didn't get to do as much you know a
lot of it didn't come to screen and she
was hoping that it wasn't going to
happen the same
and I said I don't it isn't like I mean
you're gonna go through the training
like we did we do with all our actors
like we do with Keanu or we did with
Charlize and and when you come out the
other end I'm gonna film it because it's
gonna be great and she had an aptitude
and and she was able to do a lot more
than we thought and we looked for
opportunities to put her in more action
bits as we went along just because she
was that good so hats off to her I think
she does an incredible job in this movie
and like she's created a really
compelling character for us whose idea
was it for that sequence with the one
arm with Dwayne that's awesome
when he's just you know yeah that's like
the choreography team I had like the
grit I had some great you know stunt
guys together for the choreography and
when they were building out that
sequence that was one of the things they
pitched me and I'm like it's in it's
awesome I mean it's a great hobs
defining moment when you design fight
scenes obviously you want to design them
around character and you can see in that
one you know we're really sort of divine
defining all three characters actually
because you're intercutting Shaw in the
apartment and he's fighting
Hattie's fighting like him and you're
seeing their relationship and then
you're seeing sort of this blossoming
relationship with Hattie and and Hobbes
as they're sort of flirting while
they're fighting and you know and then
you see like strength move and hurt or
relentless nature and there's a lot of
things going on that you're learning
about the characters that people just
don't think they're getting from a scene
but they're actually absorbing it and
that's why those scenes work totally I
think we have time for one more question
so I'm putting that out there does
someone have something good
wait we see it we see the hand hold on
we're gonna throw to the first row let's
not hit anyone it's a team effort yes
all right so this is kind of like a
two-parter I'm I'm Mike I was here for
dead hey Mike good awesome good to see
you it was a great Q&A thank you maybe
you both can answer this Kelly should
answer it it looks like she's ready to
dance so when you guys are producing
together and directing how do you guys
deal with like the
dress and when you guys get into like
disagree getting a disagreements onset
or and like how do you balance all that
because yes yeah please please share and
enlighten enlighten at least a few
people in here thank you go ahead no I
know really I'll start and then you can
add in so I just have so much respect
for Kelly as a producer and honestly for
where I am in the business before we
were I mean
before we were married she represented
Chad and I she was our manager and and
then our friendship sort of grew out of
that and we became really close and you
know we love we love the movie business
and we love telling stories and I have
so much respect for her obviously as a
storyteller and someone to understand
story and character and so creatively
that's there's never a really problem
I think the filmmakers job is always to
push the box but you always need the
responsible you know eyes to production
pushing it down but I don't know I think
it's just our respect for each other
what do you think she's like I could you
kept me in a box we made it for whatever
it was like all that money but I didn't
spend a dime more than whatever it was
but that's not you're not just a numbers
producer and that's the thing it's like
you need I need again like to surround
myself with the you know creative input
and people I trust because the job is
has so many responsibilities that you
want to have that team that you can rely
on and support you I think not just
because I'm his wife but because he is
so versed in production from growing up
in the you know I mean a lot of
directors just show up and haven't done
a lot of time on set
and understand the like different
apartments and collaborations and things
that need to happen and he's
particularly aware so if I'm I sit there
and go like it's gonna be your decision
or somebody else's so like here's what I
know about the landscape and you know
you can be creative in these ways and
they're going to demand these kinds of
things and so help him make the choices
so that they're not made for him if that
makes sense because it actually allows
him to be more creative I would say and
I try to do that with all my directors
but they don't quite see it or maybe
they don't trust me as much I think we
have a pretty good record so I'm like I
think it works so I don't want to go
anywhere else
I agree when I go anywhere else for my
producer or my wife I love you and that
is definitely a good way to say so again
I wonder I want to reiterate a huge
thank you to IMAX and Universal yeah for
being awesome partners a huge thank you
to David Leitch for doing the QA tonight
and letting us show the movie early and
obviously if you enjoyed the movie
please go on social media and spread the
love just don't reveal spoilers yes and
guys thanks for sitting through it and
wat and joint watching it and yes please
spread the word like we got a lot of
money a lot of money to make back
according to Kelly good thank you guys
I'm fine I love this coming up
[Applause]